today candidates for Governor discussed  key race issues Metro Sheriff Joe  Lombardo and Governor Steve CIS elect  held a q a at Red Rock Resorts over 400  members of the construction industry  attended this event one of the topics of  discussion affordable housing cost of  money  expansion of the economy quality jobs  affordable jobs jobs that pay well  and gives them the ability to fight back  things such as inflation and interest  rates that we're currently experiencing  and manage the government handout of  money that has an effect on everything  we do in society we still have more  federally available land in Nevada than  almost any state in the country and we  need to get more of that land available  now well the candidates also discussed  education local jobs and climate change  a reminder that election day is just 42  days away